the differentiable function f and its
derivative F prime are graphed so let's
see we see the graph of y is equal to f
of X here in the blue and then F prime
we see in this brownish orangish color
right over here what is an appropriate
calculus based justification for the
fact that F is decreasing when X is
greater than 3 so we can see that that
actually is indeed the case when X is
greater than 3 we see that our function
is indeed decreasing as x increases the
Y value the value of our function
decreases so a calculus based
justification without even looking at
the choices well I could look at the
derivative and we're going to be
decreasing if the slope of the tangent
line is negative which means that the
derivative is negative and we can see
that for X is greater than 3 the
derivative is less than zero so my
justification I haven't even looked at
these choices yet I would say for X is
greater than 3 f prime of X is less than
zero that would be my justification not
even looking at these choices now let's
look at the choices F prime is
decreasing
when X is greater than 3 now this isn't
right what we care about is whether f
prime is positive or negative if f prime
is negative if it's less than zero then
the function itself is decreasing the
slope of the tangent line will be
negative you could F prime could be
positive while decreasing for example F
prime could be doing something like this
and even though f prime would be
decreasing in this situation the the
actual value of the derivative would be
positive which means the function would
be increasing in that scenario so I
would rule this one out for values of X
larger than 3 as X values increase the
values of f of X decrease now that is
actually true this is actually the
definition that F is decreasing as X
values increase the values of f of X
decrease but this is not a calculus
based justification so I am going to
rule this one out as well F prime is
negative
when X is greater than three well that's
exactly what I wrote up here if F prime
is negative then that means that our
slope of the tangent line of our
original function f is going to be
downward sloping or that our function is
decreasing so this one is looking good
and this one right over here says f
prime of zero is equal to negative three
so they're just pointing out this point
this isn't even relative to the interval
that we care about or this isn't even
relative min when X is greater than
three so we definitely want to rule that
one out let's do one more of these so
here we're told the differentiable
function G and it's derivative G prime
are graphed so once again G is in this
bluish color and then G prime its
derivative is in this orange color what
is an appropriate calculus based
justification for the fact that G has a
relative minimum point at X is equal to
negative three and we could see it here
when X is equal to negative 3
it looks like G is equal to negative 6
and it looks like a relative minimum
point there so what's the best
justification so once again without even
looking at the choices I would say a
good justification is before we get to x
equals negative 3 before we get to x
equals negative 3 our derivative and
there's a calculus based justification
before we go to x equals negative 3 our
derivative is negative is negative and
after x equals negative 3 our derivative
is positive that would be my
justification because if our derivative
is positive before that valid if our
derivative is negative before that value
that means that we are downward sloping
before that value and if it's positive
after that value that means we're upward
sloping after that which is a good
justification that we are at a relative
minimum point right over there so let's
see the point where x equals negative 3
is the lowest point on the graph of G in
its surrounding interval that is true
but that's not a calculus based
justification you wouldn't even have to
look at the derivative to make that
statement
so let's rule that one out G prime has a
relative maximum at 0 comma 3 at 0
zero comma three it actually does not G
prime G prime yes G prime actually does
have a relative maximum at 0 comma 3 but
that doesn't tell us anything about
whether we're at a at a relative minimum
point at x equals negative 3 so I would
rule that out G prime of negative 3 is
equal to 0 so G prime of negative 3 is
equal to 0 so that tells us that the
slope of the tangent line of our
function is going to be 0 right over
there but that by itself is not enough
to say that we are the relative minimum
point for example I could at be at a
point that does something like this
where the slope of my tangent line is 0
and then it keeps increasing again or it
does something like this and it keeps
decreasing so even though you're at a
point where the slope of your tangent
line is 0 it doesn't mean you're at a
relative minimum point so I would rule
that out
G prime crosses the x-axis from below it
to above it at x equals negative 3 G
prime crosses the x-axis from below it
to above it yep and that's the argument
that I made that we're going from below
the x-axis so G prime goes from being
negative to positive which means the
slope of the tangent lines of our points
as we approach x equals negative 3 go
from being downward sloping to upward
sloping which is an indication that we
are at a relative minimum point